If you have a dance performance, dance is a good combination of dance and dance.
If you have a good combination of dance and dance, then you can become a very useful combination.
Hello everyone, I hope you are well and today I am here with Class 12 Chemistry
and the coordination compounds of one short video will end like always.
The whole lesson is only in one video and after watching this one video,
your concepts are crystal clear.
So, I am Rochney from LanoHab, the free learning platform
where you can learn all the Chemistry Maths by all means absolutely for free at LanoHab.com.
So, prepare everyone, let's get started.
The first question in the brain is what is coordination compounds?
Well, coordination compounds are complex molecules. Yes, they are complex, they are simple and they are not.
So, these are complex compounds that we will see in them that a metal atom
which is known as neutral molecules or anion, which means that negatively charged ions will be bound
and formed by sharing of electrons.
So, we call these compounds as coordination compounds.
For example, if you look at this coordination compound, you can see this structure.
It is simple and complex, in fact, in this lesson,
the structures that you see, they will look at them and see how complex they are.
But, it is not that complex because when you will understand basic concepts,
then everything is crystal clear.
So, let's focus on this example and see, in the middle,
in the middle, there is a love metal atom which is cobalt in this case.
Who is making a bond with cobalt?
One, two, three, four, six bonds, who is NH tree?
Ammonia. Ammonia is a neutral molecule.
So, cobalt has a neutral molecule and it is a bond.
It is a bond. It is a covalent bond.
This is not a covalent bond.
It is mutually electronically shared in covalent bond.
These two parties are shared here.
So, all this is learned slowly but first of all,
tell us why we study?
When we see these complex, we are in coordination compounds.
Because, there are many areas in these applications.
If we talk about plants, what is chlorophyll in plants?
I am sure everyone knows.
Chlorophyll is very important.
Chlorophyll is the reason for it to be made by plants.
And do you know chlorophyll is a coordination compound of magnesium.
If we talk about hemoglobin,
hemoglobin is in our blood.
If we talk about hemoglobin, then doctors eat all the medicines.
So, hemoglobin is a coordination compound of iron.
If we talk about vitamin B12, which is very difficult to create a lot of problems.
So, vitamin B12 is a coordination compound of cobalt.
Not so much.
In medicinal chemistry, textile dyeing,
in this way, even in the coordination compounds,
there is a very important role.
Many industrial catalysts, many reagents,
also use coordination compounds.
Now, to convince you to combine coordination compounds,
you have to explain the concept of coordination compounds.
There are many theories in the market.
Like, Verner's theory, Valence Bond theory,
Crystal Field theory, Molecular or Abital theory,
Lachorilly and Fild theory, Electronic theory,
so many theories.
Yes, but we will only learn three theories on the philalist level.
Verner's theory, Valence Bond theory, and Crystal Field theory.
First of all, we will talk about Verner's theory.
Verner's theory is of course,
Alfred Werner's name is named,
which he formulated for the first time,
complexes.
That is, he first showed the formula on the history of the formula.
He showed it to you earlier about his structure.
He told it so much.
Verner's first time,
about the concept of primary and secondary Valence,
now you are thinking about Valence,
but what is primary and secondary Valence?
Let us go.
Let us listen to the story from the beginning,
how Alfred Werner did it?
So, Werner has first done some complexions,
a series of compounds.
Like, what compounds are called,
cobalt chloride and ammonia compounds.
Like COCl3, 6NH3,
COCl3, 5NH3,
COCl3, 4NH3.
So, this series of compounds,
with these compounds,
reacted to the excess of silver nitrate.
What did they get?
In their solution, white precipitate,
which is the silver chloride.
That is, with all these reactions,
silver chloride was getting,
but, how much silver chloride was getting,
that was little different.
All the same silver chloride was not getting.
How did Werner know?
Werner said,
in the solution's conductivity,
he noticed that,
in the first case,
conductivity was more than,
in the second case,
in the third case.
Conductivity is more than,
when the number of ions is more than,
in the first case,
because, by ions,
they conduct.
So, this means,
in the first case,
the number of ions is more than,
in the second case,
and in the third case,
and in the third case.
So, from this experiment,
Werner had a little idea,
and what Werner did with that idea,
he formulated all these compounds,
he wrote all these compounds,
formula,
like, how?
See, Werner has understood,
that,
see,
my compound,
what was it?
COCl3NH3.
Now, we are noticing,
what is the product,
what is the AGCL?
Means, with silver,
this compound,
which part is going out,
the chloride part is going out.
Right?
So, chloride is going out
of the cobalt,
leaving it,
to get it with silver.
But,
NH3,
this cobalt,
leaving it,
is never going out.
Right?
So,
Werner has said,
that it is good.
So, if I write,
this compound,
formula,
on the other hand,
I can say,
that all these NH3,
like,
if I talk about this,
then,
these 6 NH3 molecules,
are always,
connected,
at times,
difficult times.
So, Werner has formulated,
CONH3 whole 6,
in this whole,
square,
in the packet.
Okay?
Who was leaving it?
He was leaving it,
leaving it,
to get the chloride.
So, see,
chloride was kept outside the square bracket.
You asked,
that,
I kept all the chloride outside,
so I did not keep it outside.
Because,
what he saw?
That the number of ions,
was also varying.
Right?
As,
as we were going
to the third case,
the second case,
the third case,
we were looking at,
what is the number of ions,
what is going on?
It is less.
That is,
the number of CL-
which is left out of this,
is also less.
So, if you look at this formula,
the number of,
square bracket,
the number of CL-
is less,
1,
2,
3.
So,
what do you think?
What do you think?
Because,
now,
how did he relate experiments?
So,
this experimental result,
related to,
Werner,
first time,
a scientist,
who formulated,
this way,
he formulated,
well,
so, here,
we have got two things,
this way,
the complex,
the coordination compounds,
there are some molecules,
which are completely connected,
that they are not left,
they are not ionized.
Some of them,
which are left out of the body,
well,
the ones who are not left,
they are inside the square brackets,
they can be left out of the square brackets,
and this is the beginning,
Werner theory of coordination compounds,
Werner,
first of all,
he said,
that coordination compounds,
which are in the central metal atom,
this is the two types of valencies,
primary valencies,
and secondary valencies.
What are the primary valencies?
The primary valencies,
basically,
are the oxidation number,
of the metal atom.
Ok,
oxidation number,
charge,
do you understand?
That means,
how much charge is in that metal atom,
or how much charge is in it,
if we assume that,
it is ionized.
Ok,
so,
the meaning of the word,
is that,
the primary valencies,
how is this,
is ionizable.
Right,
now, we were talking about,
that coordination compounds,
have some things inside the square brackets,
which are not ionized easily,
some things are in the square brackets,
which are ionized,
all of them are ionized.
the primary valencies,
this is ionizable.
That means,
this is ionized by a certain kind of,
it is broken in the form of an ionized,
for example,
let us suppose,
if we talk about,
this coordination compound,
K4 fec and hole 6,
ok,
look,
what is inside the square bracket,
fec and hole 6.
So,
that means,
fec and hole 6
this could never be left to one other person, or Ionize it, but what can Ionize is K plus
and the rest of the things minus, this Ionize it.
So what happens is, the ionizable that is the primary valency, so if you ever say
that the metal atom's primary valency, that means you have to remove the oxidation number
of that metal, oxidation number, we have already learnt in class 11th, but here when we
discuss, then what happens once again?
Okay, now let's talk about secondary valency.
What is secondary valency?
Now, you have guessed that the non ionizable, that means the square bracket inside,
like the FECN whole 6, in this example, these two can not break F e plus C n minus,
we cannot out-line, we cannot out-line.
So secondary valency is non ionizable, secondary valency, when we say metal atom,
then what we talk about, we talk about its coordination number.
What is coordination number?
That metal atom, how many coordinate bonds are being made?
Okay, like this.
If I talk about this example, then Ion is my central metal atom, this is how many coordinates
are being made, see the square bracket inside, this 6 C n minus is being made with
bond, that is, its coordination number is 6, that is, how many valencies are being made,
6.0.
Similarly, if we look at this second example, what is the central metal atom here?
This is how many people are connected, that is, how many amonias are connected here?
6 amonias are connected, that is, how many coordinate bonds are being made?
So, that is, how many of the coordination numbers of the cobalt are connected?
That is, how many of the cobalt's secondary valencies are connected?
So, this is the first thing, the story of the word and theory of coordination compounds.
So, the word and theory of the word, the word and theory of coordination compounds
are being made with two types of linkages.
Primary linkages and secondary linkages are being made with two types of valencies,
primary valencies and secondary valencies.
If we talk about primary valencies, what is primary valencies?
That is, this is the oxidation number of metal.
Oxidation number is the charge of metal.
If we assume that metal ionized, how much charge will be applied on it?
That is basically the oxidation number.
Okay?
So, as we discussed earlier, that primary valencies are normally ionizable.
That means, if we talk about the coordination compound,
let us say K4 FeCN whole 6.
Okay?
So, in this compound, if you look at the square brackets, what is the output of the square brackets?
So, how does it ionize on the surface?
K plus ion is out and FeCN whole 6 minus is out of the axis.
Right?
So, this is ionizable.
So, the ionizable is basically the primary valency or primary linkage.
Okay?
So, the second thing is that the square brackets are not dissociated from the ions.
And that is where we talk about secondary valency.
So, the secondary valency of metal is basically the coordination number.
That means, the metal is the second ion or the second molecule.
So, the second molecule is made up of the two coordinates.
That tells you the coordination number.
The secondary valency is always non-ionizable.
That means, whatever happens, if you come here, you come here.
But, this is not dissociated in the ions of the ions.
So, if we talk about the coordination compound,
FeCN whole 6th compound, then here, my secondary valency is so much.
How much is the secondary valency of iron?
Look at the diameter of the iron.
So, the secondary valency of iron is 6th and the secondary valency of iron is 6th.
So, the secondary valency of iron is 6th.
If we take another example,
in this coordination compound, what is our central metal atom?
Cobalt.
Cobalt with the secondary valency of iron is 6th.
So, the secondary valency of coal will also be 6th.
Now, if you talk about the primary valency, how do we take out the metal oxidation number?
How do we take out the oxidation number?
We have already learnt this in class 11.
Even now, when we practice some questions,
then there will be a quick recap.
This is the third concept of the next concept of coordination polyhedron.
Coordination polyhedron, how do we call it?
Well, what we have learnt from the theory of the verner,
is that the metal is made of secondary linkages.
And that is how they form the coordination bonds.
So, this metal atom along with the secondary linkages,
which is made of a specific spatial arrangement.
Let us suppose, here there is a central metal atom.
Now, this central metal atom is making 4 coordinate bonds.
So, this is a bond, this is a bond, this is a bond.
Now, this 4 coordinate bonds make this specific spatial arrangement.
For example, a tetrahedral arrangement is made.
So, the square brackets inside the part,
which is made of secondary linkages,
is always a specific spatial arrangement,
which we can say is a specific geometry.
And we call this thing as coordination polyhedron.
Now, just like coordination number changes,
like if a central atom is connected to 4 and a half things.
Like, 4 coordinate bonds are made.
So, the coordination number is 4.
So, in that case, the spatial arrangement is a tetrahedron.
It means, 4 phases of structure.
So, this is the structure of this way.
Right?
Where there is a central atom,
and this central atom is made of a bond,
a bond, a bond, a bond, and a bond.
And this is the structure of this way.
This is 4 phases of structure tetrahedron.
1 phase A, 1 phase A, 1 phase A, and 1 phase A.
So, total 4 phases, that is why tetrahedron.
So, this is another polyhedra,
which is the central atom.
And this is 4 coordinate bonds.
One bond is made.
So, this is a different spatial arrangement.
So, here, I have a coordination polyhedron.
Square planer polyhedron.
See, the square is made of a square,
which is the square planer.
Now, if you have arranged something,
where the center atom is in the center,
and this is a total 6 coordinate bond.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5 and 6.
If you are making 6 coordinate bonds,
then see, how the polyhedron is made.
This is a polyhedron,
which has total 8 phases.
And that is why it is called octahedron polyhedra.
How are these 8 phases?
1, 2, 3, 4 and in the same way,
1, 2, 3, 4.
So, total 8 phases, polyhedron,
which we call octahedron polyhedron.
So, in the same way,
there is something called u,
or coordination compounds,
which are part of square brackets.
That is, the part metal and other ions
are made of secondary link between the molecules.
What happens in that?
The second link is also called
a definite spatial arrangement.
A definite spatial arrangement is also called
a specific geometry.
And where we are talking about definite arrangement,
and where we are talking about directional.
That means, the arrangement here is
being in a particular direction,
in an orientation.
And that is why we call it the coordinate bond.
This is the directional.
So, the word theory is called C.
We found out that the combination compound
of this is called secondary link.
That is basically the form of coordination polyhedron.
So, some coordination polyhedron examples
we will talk about by taking specific examples.
First example is CONH3 whole 6-3+.
So, here we see our central metal atom is CO.
CO is connected to 6 ammonia molecules.
So, assume that the whole structure of this
between the two are cobalt.
This is 1, 2, 3, 4, 5 and 6 ammonia.
So, we will get an octahedron.
Right?
Now, let us take a second example.
CO, CL, NH3 whole 5, 2+.
Here, you will say that the ma'm CO is connected
with 5 NH3 but it is also connected with 1 CL.
Because, the 1 CL is in the square bracket.
So, in the circle, 5 NH3 and 1 CL
are also making total 6 bonds.
So, here, the structure of the polyhedron
will be the octahedron.
If we talk about CO, CL2, NH3 whole 4+.
So, here, cobalt 2 chlorine and 4 NH3 are connected.
So, in the circle, how many people are connected?
So, coordination number is also the sixth.
The geometry of the structure of the structure of the structure
or the spatial arrangement is also connected to the octahedron.
So, these three examples are the octahedral entities.
Let us talk about the 4th of the NICO whole 4.
So, the structure of the structure is connected with 4 CO groups.
So, if the structure is connected with 1, 2, 3, 4 CO groups,
the structure of the structure is connected with the structure of the structure of the structure.
So, this is tetrahedral entity.
If we talk about the PTCL42- here,
the platinum central atom is connected to the 4 chlorine atoms.
So, how do I get the entity of the structure of the structure?
The square plane is in a plane and this is the form of a square.
So, how do I get the polyhedron of the structure of the structure of the structure?
The square plane.
Now, you might think how exactly we know
how the shape of the tetrahedral is,
whether it is a square or octahedron.
So, I will show you the formula and tell you that
if it is connected to the structure of the structure, this is the geometry.
But, exactly how do I know?
We will learn a little bit about coordination compounds in a different theory.
So, as we start studying about these complexes,
then we start studying a doubt automatically in the brain.
Do we have a complex ions like double salts?
Well, not really.
Complexes or double salts, they are two other things.
But, why is it confusion?
Because, there are some similarities in both.
Double salts or complexes.
Both of them are made by combination of stable compounds in a stoichiometric ratio.
So, these two are similar, but why are they different?
The first difference is that double salts exist in the state generally.
And, the second and most importantly, the difference is that
is this, that if we dissolve in water,
then these simple ions dissociate.
For example, let us talk about potash alum, which is a double salt.
If we dissolve it in water, then we get potassium,
iron, aluminum, iron, sulphate, iron, etc.
Because, these ions get ionized in their ions.
Dissociate them.
If we talk about complexes, then we know that
the complexes in the inner square bracket,
that is, the secondary linkage, that is,
then, it is used to dissolve in water.
It is not dissociated in water.
For example, the FECN whole 6, 4 minus.
If we dissolve it in water,
we should dissolve it in water.
It will never be like this, that this iron and CN minus,
FEC plus and CN minus, dissociate, it will never be like this.
This is our human body.
How does it work?
We need to understand that, first of all,
which body parts are in our human body?
If we look at it, when we are very young,
we can learn from 2-3 years from the age of 2-3 years.
Which body are in our body?
These are the ears, eyes, nose, mouth, etc.
After that, gradually, as we grow,
we can learn gradually what is the function of these parts.
And then gradually, we learn how our overall
body functions.
Similarly, the coordination chemistry is starting.
First, we are starting out,
the coordination chemistry is starting out.
Now, we are just looking at coordination compounds.
So, first of all, what we have to see?
A coordination compound of body parts.
Exactly.
So, here we will talk about the different parts of coordination compounds.
Like, what is the central metal atom,
like ligand, coordination number,
coordination entity, density, oxidation number of central atom.
What is homo-leptic and heterolptic complexes?
When we understand all these things,
at least we will understand one basic thing about the coordination compounds
which we will continue to study further.
So, first of all, we will start with coordination entity.
What is coordination entity?
What is our central metal atom?
And the one who is surrounding it,
which is called as INC molecule,
is called as INC.
It is called coordination entity.
Let us see the example.
Let us suppose, we have a coordination compound COCl3 and NH3 whole three.
So, here, what is my central atom?
What is CO?
That is, cobalt.
What is connected with cobalt?
Three COCls and three NH3s.
So, this is a whole coordination entity.
If we talk about the NiCO whole four,
then the central atom is surrounded by four CO.
And this entire thing is a coordination entity.
Now, for you, one question.
Let us suppose, we have a coordination compound of K4,
FECN whole six.
So, here, coordination entity is the concept.
So, what is central atom?
FE, that is, iron.
And iron is surrounded by CN whole six.
That is, 6 CNC surrounded.
Which is seen in square brackets.
And this whole thing is a coordination entity.
The next number is central metal atom or central metal ion.
What is this?
As we have learnt, we are now inside the coordination entity.
The inside of the coordination entity is connected with all these things.
All these ions or molecules,
which, particularly, surround the atom or the ion,
we call them central atom or central ion.
Okay? Let us see the example.
COCl NH3 whole five two plus.
Here, what will be the central atom?
Cobalt.
Because, which cobalt is surrounded by?
One COCl and five NH3.
Cobalt is surrounded by, so, cobalt is here in central atom.
If we talk about FECN whole six three minus.
So, here, my central atom is FE,
which is surrounded by, which is surrounded by,
so many CNs.
So, what is this?
This is our FE, our central atom.
Okay?
Now, when we are talking about central atom,
here, I am going to tell you about a super,
super important concept.
So, all of you, all of you,
all of you, all of you, all of you,
understand this.
Okay?
I had told you before that,
these coordination compounds,
these bonds are made,
central metal atoms,
and the surrounding ions
or molecules,
they are not exactly covalent bonds.
The bond is called covalent bond,
and it is a special thing.
Okay?
So, I am going to tell you the special thing.
So, first of all, let us remember
that in a normal covalent bond,
what happened?
Like, two atoms.
I have told you,
I give you an electron,
one electron,
and then,
these two electrons,
we will share them.
Okay?
So, this was the covalent bond.
There was a second scenario,
where, I don't have the power to give an electron.
I need an electron.
I have an electron extra,
so, I am thinking,
how do I give this electron to someone?
In such situation,
what happened?
In front of me,
I give an electron.
So, here,
the transfer of electrons
was made from ionic bond
or electromagnetic bond.
Okay?
Here, what happens in the covalent bond?
Look,
there is something like the covalent bond,
that is,
it is a covalent bond.
That is,
between both of them,
it is a electron share.
But,
both of them
don't contribute equally.
Like,
what happens in the covalent bond?
I have given one,
you have given one,
and our bond is made.
Or,
here,
I will not give anything.
Both the electrons,
you will give them.
And, after that,
the two electrons
will be formed,
we will share.
Okay?
So, this is called covalent bond.
So, this means,
in coordination compounds,
which is our central metal atom,
what does it do?
It accepts the electron.
It accepts the pair of electrons.
That is,
it is not a data.
What does it do?
It only accepts the electron
that is given in front of the electron.
It gives two electrons in front of them,
which are formed in the middle of them.
Okay?
So, the central metal atom,
in coordination compounds,
which behave like this,
it behaves like the Lewis acids.
Because,
because these electrons
don't give.
And,
children,
you will understand this concept well.
Now, you will understand that,
how is covalent bond
different from covalent bond?
The next number is the ligands.
What is ligands?
Now,
the coordination entity
between the central atoms
and the ions or molecules,
we call them ligands.
Okay?
Now, ligands,
these are simple ions,
such as Cl minus,
okay?
Cl minus is possible ligands.
These ligands,
these neutral molecules
can also be used as NH3,
as NH2,
these are all neutral molecules.
Okay?
These ligands can also be
a little bigger molecules,
such as,
ithane 1 2 diamin,
NH2, CH2, CH2,
NH2,
look, a little bigger molecule,
but still,
this can be a ligand.
This is a macro molecule,
such as proteins,
such a large molecule can also be used as ligands.
For example,
let's say,
we talk about this coordination compound,
CO, NH3 whole 6,
3 plus.
What is the central atom here?
CO,
that is, cobalt.
What is connected to cobalt here?
Tell me,
NH3.
So, what is the ammonia here?
ligand.
So, the child who is ligand,
what he has to do is
make a bond with these metals.
Okay?
As I told you,
what is this Lewis acid in the central metal atom?
That is,
he has to accept the electron.
So, this means that
if he has to make a bond with this metal atom,
then he has to give the electron
to donate,
donate,
so, this means that
if there is any atom inside the ligand,
then it should be the donor.
So,
it is necessary to donate the donor atoms.
Okay?
Now, in ligands,
we can get 1 donor atom,
1 can be a single atom.
Based on that,
we can categorize many ligands in categories.
Like,
first,
unidentate ligand or monodentate ligand.
Unidentate ligand or monocommitla means 1.
This is the same ligand
which has 1 unidentate ligand.
For example,
if we talk about CL-K,
CL-Clorean is
the same extra pair of electrons
which is given in the DNA.
Okay?
If we talk about H2O,
water,
then H2O is the oxygen-based
extra electrons,
which is given in the DNA.
If we talk about
the same NH3,
then in H3,
nitrogen-based extra electrons
are given in the DNA.
So,
in all these examples,
we see that
my ligand is
like ammonia.
So,
nitrogen atoms
and hydrogen atoms
are also known as
hydrogen atoms.
So, in all these examples,
in the same donor atom,
this is why all these unidentate
or monodentate ligands are given.
The second type of ligand
is by-identate or by-identate.
By-identate or by-identate.
This means that
two ligands have two donor atoms.
Okay?
For example,
if we talk about
the oxalate ion,
C2O42-
if you look at its structure,
then you can see that
two oxygen atoms
behave like donor atoms.
So, this is
by-identate.
Now, look at the
dentate word.
Dentate,
you remember the dentists
and dentists.
the dentists.
Right?
They have two-dentates.
Two-dentates
can be caught
with any metal bond.
You can make it like this.
Remember it.
Remember it better.
Okay?
So, if we talk about by-identate ligands,
here we can take another example.
Ethane 12 diamin.
If you look at its structure,
here again,
two nitrogen atoms
behave like donor atoms.
Okay?
Now, the third category is
poly-identate ligands.
It is known as poly-mini.
So, this is the same
ligands that have two
adheck,
which are donor atoms.
An example is
EDTA, which is called
Ethane diamin tetraacetate ion.
Okay?
If you look at its structure,
there are two nitrogen and
four oxygen atoms
that behave like donor.
So, this is the ligand.
It has a total
4 plus 2 total
6,
this is the same as donor atoms.
This is to be more specific
a hexadentate ligand.
So, it is said that
if you have to make a bond,
then you have 6-dentate
options.
Right? So, 6-dentate
is the same as
a hexadentate ligand.
Now, let's talk about
a special type of ligand.
It is called
ambidentate ligand.
What can be ambidentate?
It is
sometimes called ambidextras.
It is a word
used for this word,
which can be written
both right hand and left hand.
This word is
previously used for
this kind of ligand.
Now,
until we talked about
the identity of ligand,
we were saying that
there are two donor atoms in this ligand.
But, what did you
look at?
We talked about
the oxalate ion.
So, there was
two donor atoms oxygen.
If we were
going to die of the amine,
then there were both
donor atoms.
Nitrogen was there.
But,
we will talk about
ambidentate ligand
in this ligand,
which have two different donor atoms. Exactly that's why I said that you can write it from the right hand and from the left hand
you can write both different atoms. There is something here, in the ambidentity ligand, there are two different donor atoms
and they are both capable of making a bond with the central metal atom.
So, this is the case of the main band. For example, there is an example of the Cn-science.
So, these ions are in the case of sulfur atoms, and they have extra electrons.
So, they can behave like donor atoms and make a bond with the metal.
The nitrogen, which is also an extra electron, can be made with metal atoms.
If the Cn-metal atom is made through a bond with the sulfur, then it is made with thio cyanate.
If the Cn-metal atom is made through a bond with the through metal, then it is made with thio cyanate.
So, you see, there are two different atoms in the bond, so the product is completely different.
Similarly, if we talk about anotomyinous, then the nitrogen can behave like donor atoms and oxygen can behave like donor atoms.
And you see, when the nitrogen will be made through a bond, then how will the oxygen will be made through a bond?
So, this is the ambidentity ligand.
Another special type of ligand, which we call as keylet ligands.
Keylet ligands, what happens?
Many times, the biidentity ligands or polyidentity ligands,
the two or two different atoms are made by the same time simultaneously with the central metal atom.
So, this is how we call the ligands, keylet ligands and the complexes are made by the same, keylet complexes.
Do you understand how this is made?
No, I understand.
Let's take an example.
We will take an example of the ethylene diamine cadmium complex.
So, cadmium is my central metal atom here and ethylene diamine is ligand.
Ethylene diamine, if we remember, then it has a structure that contains two nitrogen, donor atoms.
Now, what happens to make this complex when it is made by the same central metal atom,
that is, with the same cadmium, we make the same bond with the same time.
That is, cadmium is made by the same amount of nitrogen.
So, this is called keylet complex.
When the two donor atoms are made by the same metal atom,
we call it keylet ligand and we call it a keylet complex.
Keylet complex is a special thing, that this complex is much more stable.
Why is it more stable?
Logically, think.
In this way, two or two or three atoms are made by the metal atom.
So, obviously, with the metal atom, this ligand is very firmly attached.
Now, if it is firmly attached, then obviously, its stability is much more.
Maybe, you would be curious, why does it say keylet compound?
Or, where did the keylet come from?
Well, so, this keylet is a Greek word keylet, which means, it is a claw.
Sometimes, lobster or crab, what are the claws of the crab?
How do they catch things?
How do they catch multiple claws?
They catch one thing. Right? It is grabbed basically.
So, keylet complexes also have a certain kind of effect,
that there is a legend, which has two or two different kinds of claws.
And all the claws are attached with one metal atom.
That is why the name keylet complexes.
So, children, now we have now talked about the monodentate by dented,
polydented ligands.
So, when we talk about the ligands here,
there is a term, which we call it dented city.
Dented city is basically, basically,
that the number of donor atoms' help is made with the metal bond.
Like, if we talk about a monodentate ligand, then there is a denticity of one.
If we talk about the bidentity ligand, then there is a denticity of two.
If we talk about the triidentity ligand, then there is a denticity of three.
The hexadentity ligand is 6. Right? And so on.
The next number is the coordination number.
Although, the coordination number of the number is also discussed in the information field.
But let us now look at the detail.
The coordination number means that our metal atom,
which is our central atom, is connected directly with the donor atoms.
That means, the donor atoms' bond is basically made with the donor atoms.
That is the coordination number.
Okay? Let us take an example.
Let us say, PT CL6-2-
Here, what is central atom? PT, that is, platinum.
Platinum directly attached to so many ligands,
6 ligands, 6 CL- attached.
So, coordination number is 6.
NINH3 whole 4 2 plus.
Here, in central metal atom, nickel, nickel, say,
so many ligands attached, 4 NH3 attached.
So, coordination number is 4.
If we talk about Fe-C2-O4 whole 3-3 minus.
So, what is the central metal atom here?
Fe, that is, iron.
Now, if I ask you how much coordination number will be,
many children will look at this formula and say,
that if these three C2-O4 are attached, then coordination number 3.
And as you said, your answer will be wrong.
Why will it be wrong? Think carefully.
What is C2-O4? Ox-Zalate iron.
C2-O4 structure is like this.
C2-O4 is like this, by dented ligand.
Oxygen atoms behave like donor atoms.
Now, if we look at this complex structure,
iron has been connected to three oxalates.
But in a single oxalate iron, there are two two donor atoms.
So, in a single oxalate iron, there are two two donor atoms
with metal atoms that are making two sigma bonds.
So, all the iron that is made of sigma bonds,
how many donor atoms are made with the bond?
6. So, this is the coordination number 6.
So, to find out this coordination number,
you have to see that central metal atom
is making sigma bonds with how many donor atoms.
So, the focus is not on the number of ligands.
The focus is on the number of donor atoms of the ligands.
Let us see the COEN whole 3-3+.
What is the EN here?
EN is short form, and the ETHEN 12 diamine is called.
So, here cobalt is obviously my central metal atom.
EN is my ligand, but EN again is how ligand is by dented ligand.
ETHEN 12 diamine can behave like donor atoms in two nitrogen atoms.
So, here also, the cobalt is connected to the ETHEN 3 ligands.
But, every ligand has two donor atoms with the central metal atom.
So, the total of these bonds is being formed with the donor atoms.
So, the coordination number is 6.
Now, let us talk about the coordination sphere.
What is coordination sphere?
The central metal atom or ion is attached to the ligands.
We call them co-ordination sphere.
In fact, the coordination compound square bracket is called co-ordination sphere.
The ionizable part of the co-ordination sphere is called counter ions.
For example, K4 FeCN whole 6.
See, what is inside the square bracket?
FeCN whole 6.
That is, Fe and CN, Ionize are never the same.
So, this FeCN whole 6 is the coordination sphere.
What is the central metal atom?
Fe and ligand is CN minus.
So, what is the ionizable part of the co-ordination sphere?
So, this K plus here, the potassium here is called the counter ion.
Next in Q is oxidation number of the central atom.
Okay.
Oxidation number of the central atom basically is the primary valency of the central atom.
So, what is this?
This is the fact that the central atom will charge as much as possible.
If we assume that we remove all the ligands.
But, if we assume that the central atom is attached to ligands, right?
Assume that if the ligands are not going anywhere, assume that if the ligands are removed,
along with the electrons that the ligands gave the central atom.
So, the central atom will charge as much as possible.
We call it the oxidation number of the central atom.
Okay.
Example it.
Let us suppose, we have a complex CU, CN whole 4, 3 minus.
So, what we notice here is that CN is the minus.
CN is the minus 1 charge.
So, how many CN here are there?
Whole 4, that is, total 4 CN.
So, what is the total CN unit charge?
How much is the minus 4?
Okay.
Copper is in our central atom and the oxidation number is removed.
So, we assume that copper is the oxidation number of the x.
So, total copper and CN total charge will be how much?
x plus minus 4.
And this should be equal to how much?
The net is the charge of this net, which is given here as minus 3.
So, x plus minus 4 is equal to minus 3.
So, if we take the x value here, x is equal to plus 1.
So, what is plus 1?
Plus 1 is the oxidation number of copper.
So, here the oxidation number of the central atom is plus 1.
So, how do we denote this?
We will write copper, that is, CU.
We will write in the first bracket, we will write in the Roman numeral, 1.
Because copper charge is plus 1.
So, we will write in the Roman numeral, 1.
Okay.
So, in this way, if we denote the oxidation number of central atom.
Let me tell you, children, this is super important.
You should take the oxidation number, remove it, because as we go ahead,
we will have to remove the oxidation number of central atom of the central atom.
So, if you do not come there, you will go ahead and you will go ahead.
So, I would advise you, when you have understood this,
then try to calculate the oxidation number of the central atom of the two four examples.
So, coordination compounds, which were studied by body parts,
we have covered all the body parts.
So, right now, we will be discussing the last small topic,
which is homo-laptic and hetero-laptic complexes.
Homo means the same, hetero means the different, homo-laptic complex.
So, where we have the central atom of the central atom,
it is attached to the same type of donor groups.
Means, like CO NH3 whole 6, 3 plus.
Here, the central atom is cobalt, that is, CO.
These are all the donor atoms attached, they are all ammonia, they are all same.
So, this is how it is complex, homo-laptic complex.
So, the hetero-laptic complex, which will be the central metal atom,
these all the donor groups attached will not be the same,
they will be different, that is hetero-laptic.
For example, CO NH3 whole 4 CL2 plus.
Here, see, cobalt is our central atom,
cobalt is attached to 4 NH3 and 2 CLs,
that is, the different, different donor groups are attached,
then this is the hetero-laptic complex.
Children, think that if you and your friends
had no name, then how would it be?
How convenient would it be, right?
Like, if you have to call any friend,
then listen, listen, how many friends you call,
if you have 5 friends at a time, then addressing them
would have been so difficult, right?
For a teacher, if they have no name,
So, naming is very important.
So, the way children are naming,
it is very important, the coordination compounds,
the name of the current is very important,
and where it comes from, the name of the current is called,
IUPAC, International Union of Pure and Applied Chemistry.
So, children, in this section, we will learn how to name
the coordination compounds, and in this time,
we will learn two things.
If we have a formula or structure, then how will we write its name?
If we have a name, then how will we make its structure?
So, children, let's learn the name of the non-inclature,
some rules, i.e. the name, i.e. the name of the name,
or the structure, which follows, we will do the name of any structure.
So, our first rule, we will always write the name of the name,
we will write the name, followed by anion.
So, you know what anion is, anion,
A-negative ion.
So, the negative ion, that is anion,
which is positive ion, that is the cation.
For example, if we look at this coordination compound,
then the value of the value of the value of the value of the value of the value of the value,
is anion, then the positive ion, that is the cation.
If we talk about this example,
then again, the negative ion, which is a negative ion,
that is a negative ion, that is the cation.
So, the name of the cation, we always write it first and then anion.
Whereas, positive is always good, right?
So, this is the positive ion, first, then negative ion.
Rule number two.
When we name the complex, the name of the ligand is first written,
then we write the central metal atom.
For example, if we look at this formula,
here, the chromium is our central metal atom,
and what is the ligand?
NH3 is our one ligand, H2O is our one more ligand.
So, when we write its name, then it looks like this.
Try Amine, try Acqua Chromium 3 chloride.
So, look carefully, try Amine.
Amine first written, try Acqua.
Acqua is also written, Amine is for NH3,
aqua is for H2O, then it is chromium.
Right? So, we write the ligand first, then we write the central metal atom.
So, this was our rule number two.
Rule number three.
No space between metal atom and ion and the ligands.
When we write the name, then we do not give space between ligands and metal atom.
As you can see, I just told you this name.
Try Amine, try Acqua Chromium 3 chloride.
Look, after trying Amine, it is not written by space.
Try Acqua.
After trying Acqua, it is not written by space.
So, between metal, central metal atom and ligands,
there is no space in between.
Now, we have told you that the name of ligand
is first from the central metal atom.
But, ligand's naming is also a lot of rules.
Because, there is no ligand, there are many times, many times, many times, many times, many times.
So, now we will learn rules to name the ligands.
Okay? First rule.
If we have anionic ligands, that is, ligands, which is anion, ligands, which is negative charge.
If we have ligands, then their name will always be O to the end.
For example, CL-
we will write Clory-
BR-
Bromido
OH-
we will write Hydroxydo.
So, look, all the names are ending from O to the end.
Now, that is very specific to anionic ligands.
Okay?
This is rule number 1.
Rule number 2, this is said that whenever we have more than one ligand,
we will write in the case order, we will decide based on the alphabetical order.
As you can see, we are looking at this coordination compound.
We have 1 ligand in H3, 1 more ligand in H2.
Okay?
So, that is anionic ligand and 1 aqua.
Right?
It is a two-dimensional ligand.
Now, in these two ligands, we will write in the first name, we will write in the first name, aqua.
Right?
So, for alphabetical, A, M is first from A Q.
Correct?
It is first from M.
So, this is why when we write its name, we write in the first name,
try, amine, try, aqua, chromium, three, chloride.
Right?
So, alphabetical order, we follow.
Rule number 3.
If we have the same ligand in H, we will use the pre-fixes,
like di, tri, tetra, etc.
Okay?
Again, let us look at this example.
Here, look at the amine group.
The N-H3 ligand is so much, three.
That is why we have written in the name, tri amine.
That is, three amines.
Similarly, the H2 ligand is so much, three.
That is why we have written tri aqua.
This is a situation where N-H3 is the fourth.
So, we will write in the name, tetra amine.
If there is a situation where N-H3 is the second,
then we will write in the name, di amine and so on.
Rule number 4.
If we are talking about the ligand, which is polyidentity ligand.
Polyidentity ligand means that ligand is two to the right.
And that is making all the ligands with the central metal atom bond.
Okay?
So, here we use an additional prefix,
like Bist, Trist, Tetracus and so on.
Bist means 2, Trist means 3, Tetracus means 4.
Now, you will say that we have written this Bist, Trist, Tetracus.
We could have done this with di terayi tetra,
we could not have done it.
Why should I tell you?
We have a biidentity ligand, which is the one to di amine.
Now, the one to di amine is already di amine.
Now, if we also write di out,
then it is a little difficult to understand that
what is the meaning of di?
That this ligand is two, like di amine.
That means, it is two amine groups.
But here we are not going to say that.
We are saying that this ligand is one,
but it is the multiple of ligand.
So, you are understanding the difference.
So, we cannot use the same prefix.
When we try to use di tetra,
that means that this ligand is two times,
or this ligand is four times.
But when we use Bist, Trist, Tetracus,
then we are saying that the ligand is polyidentity ligand.
And how many of its teeth is that,
it tells us Bist, Trist, Tetracus.
Okay, as an example,
if we look at the structure,
Trist, ethane, one, two, di amine, chromium, three, chloride.
So, here we are saying,
what ligand is we are talking about,
we are talking about ethane, one, two di amine.
Which is a biidentity ligand.
So, we have used di in that.
The moment we are saying,
Trist, what are we trying to say,
that this type of ligand,
this type of ligand is three times.
Correct.
If you want, we can write it as,
try ethane, one, two, di amine.
So, here, even in di amine,
there is also di,
there is also a tri.
So, this is a confusion.
So, in such cases,
in this case, in the case of polyidentity ligands,
we use Trist in the case of tri.
Okay.
Finally, rule number five.
Where we also use polyatomic ligands.
That is, ligands, which have one and a half atoms.
Like, I mean, NH3.
There is nitrogen atom and hydrogen atom.
Like, H2O.
There is hydrogen atom and oxygen atom.
So, wherever we use polyatomic ligands,
we put the ligands inside the brackets.
Right. If you look at the formula of their formula,
what we do is, we put NH3 inside the bracket.
H2O is the first bracket inside the bracket.
Okay. So, like NH3 whole three,
that is, NH3 is total three such NH3.
Right.
So, it is important that we put the polyatomic ligands
inside the first bracket.
So, we have seen the rules of ligands.
Now, let us save the central atom.
So, let us see the rules of central atom.
So, central atom is the first rule of all.
Oxidation number of the central atom.
The central atom, whatever the central atom is,
we will write the symbol of its symbol.
For example, let us see in this situation, copper.
Let us say, for example, in this coordination compound,
our central metal atom is chromium.
Chromium's oxidation number is found out.
Let us say, here, chromium's oxidation number is plus 3.
How to found out that is your homework?
Because oxidation number is found out.
I have taught.
So, let us take a look at the number of the feta-farts.
Is it coming out of the blue?
No, it is not.
So, let us write this.
When we do this called, we will write in the chromium bracket,
we will write in the Roman numerals.
Okay?
That is how we represent the oxidation number of the central atom.
So, remember, I told you before that,
the central atom's oxidation number is very critical.
That is, if you want to do a compound's name,
then you also have to do a central atom's oxidation number.
Because that is something that you have to mention here.
Okay?
So, how to find out the name of this compound?
Try Amin, try Acqua, Chromium 3, chloride.
Okay?
Try Amin, try Acqua.
It is a ligand part.
I have told you that, because it is written in the alphabetical order,
that is why Amin is first in Acqua,
because it is NH3, it is H2O3,
that is why it is tri-tri-prifix.
If we talk about the central atom's chromium,
then the first bracket's oxidation number is in Roman numerals.
And what is the name of this?
Now, I can understand how step by step we have learnt how to name the whole thing.
Okay?
So, this was the first rule for the naming of central atom.
The second rule of central atom is naming.
If we have a complex, that is a neutral complex,
then the normal chemical name will be called.
But if the complex is an anionic complex,
that is the complex part, then we can understand it.
Now, we can say that the complex is the third bracket's inner part,
which is the complex.
So, the square brackets have the inner part,
if that overall has a negative charge,
then we say it is anionic,
like K2 ZnOH whole four.
So, here if we have to do this,
then how will we make anionic K plus?
Which will be the cation part,
and ZnOH whole four minus,
that is, this is anion part.
So, that is, here my complex part,
that is anionic complex.
So, whenever anionic complex is also anionic,
then anionic complex's name is,
it is called a suffix,
A-T-E.
Okay?
If we do this compound naming,
then as I told you about naming,
first we have to do the first,
then what is the first name of the name of the potassium?
Then what will be the next name of the complex?
The first name of the complex will be,
Ligand, right?
Ligand is OH whole four,
that is tetrahydroxo.
Okay?
Because OH minus anionic ligand is,
that is why Oc is the end of the body.
So, tetrahydroxo,
then Zincate instead of Zinc,
it will be Zincate.
Because this complex is anionic complex.
Do you understand?
Look, it will be a little complex,
it will be a little complex,
because the rules are not at your fingertips.
But I am trying to explain to you,
the rules that are applied to it,
we have discussed all these.
Okay?
So, if you are used to these rules,
you know,
naming will become very easy.
So, I understood how we named it.
Okay?
Now, Zincate is not finished,
after Zincate,
we have added two in the bracket,
because here,
the central metal atom is,
which is Zinc in this case,
it is not potassium,
potassium is the counterion, right?
So, Zinc is the central atom in this case,
so Zincate oxidation number,
and that is plus two.
So, let us start with our practice time,
or practice time,
which means,
we have to solve the two seven questions together.
Okay?
Here, we have given a coordination compound,
which we have to name.
What is the first step of the name?
We have to find out anion and anion.
Okay?
Because we first name the cation.
So, here,
look carefully,
if we look here,
what we are seeing here?
Selfate.
How is it charged in self-fate?
Negative charge.
Which means,
this is our anion.
Okay?
And from that,
the thing that is being seen,
this is our cation.
The rules of the naming of cation
are called the rules of the naming of cation.
Okay?
So, let us do it first.
So, our whole focus is on this cation.
Okay?
So, what we have learnt in cation,
is that we will do the naming of cation
in the name of the cation.
So, first, identify the name of the cation.
Now, look.
Here, you can see that,
this cobalt is our central atom.
Okay?
So, now,
which is the ligand of my central atom?
The part that is connected to the central atom.
So, this is my ligand.
Okay?
Let me write this.
Now, let us remember the rules.
First, we will name the cation.
And, maybe, the name of ligand is first.
Okay?
So, now, what is the focus on ligand?
So, look.
If we focus on ligand,
this is our ligand.
So, which ligand is this?
CH2CH2,
two carbon-wala,
in which two, what is it?
Amine, NH2, NH2,
and NH2 is it.
Right?
So, this is ethane 12 di amine.
So, what is the name of our ligand?
Ithane 12 di amine.
Okay?
But, what is our ligand?
Ithane is not ithane.
Look, it is hole 3.
What is the meaning of this?
It is 3.
Now, look,
this ligand's name is used in the di.
Right?
So, for this,
we will write this,
we will write this as a trial.
No,
our rule was that,
we write in such cases,
tris.
Okay?
So, the name of ligand is finished.
Perfect.
After ligand,
we name it central atom.
Central atom here,
cobalt.
Co is cobalt.
So, write cobalt.
After cobalt,
we write in bracket,
cobalt's oxidation number.
Okay?
Now, how to get the oxidation number?
How?
How to calculate its oxidation value?
You calculate the value of the oxidation.
So, let us go.
How to calculate the oxidation number?
Okay.
Let us assume that cobalt's oxidation number is x.
Now,
this is the ethane 12 di amine.
How much is it charged?
0 charge.
And net net is the entire ion charge.
If we look at the amount of fat,
you will say 0,
but 0 is actually not.
Right?
Because, look,
this is connected with the same amount of fat,
which is 3 here.
So, basically, if this ionized,
then the SO4 2 minus will go
and this 3 or this 3 will go here.
3 plus will go up.
Right?
This 3 will go up here.
3 plus.
Right?
So, in this case,
3 will go up.
Because,
what does the charge mean?
If this ionized will go up,
then how much will it charge?
Right?
That means,
if this ionized,
then the SO4 will go up.
And this entire cation will go up.
So, cation will go up.
Net net plus 3 will charge.
Which we have written.
So, this means,
x value will go up.
plus 3.
Okay?
That means,
this cobalt is the oxidation state.
We will write in Roman numerals.
3.
Okay?
So,
now, look,
we have written the name of the cation.
We have written.
And I am not doing anything.
And I am saying,
sulfate.
We will do it here.
Here is the name.
Let us see the second example.
A.G. NH3 whole 2, A.G. CN whole 2.
Okay?
We have to name it.
First step,
cation and anion are to identify.
Now,
look at this question here.
How will you think that,
see it easily,
we cannot tell you what cation it will be.
Which anion it will be.
What anion it will be.
It should be positive in the net net.
It should be negative in the anion.
So, let us calculate and see.
How much is it?
Now, see.
If we focus on this,
then,
A.G. is over
plus 1.
C.N. is over minus 1.
But, C.N. is 2.
That means,
net net C.N. is over minus 2.
So, how much is the net net charge on it?
Minus 1.
Negative charge is there.
Which means,
we have found out that
what this is.
This is our anion.
Now,
if this is anion,
then what will happen?
This will obviously be cut.
And,
if you look at the NH3,
there is 0 A.G.
Plus 1.
So,
net net plus 1 charge.
So, that is cut iron.
Okay?
So, first step is done.
Now, first of all,
we will call it the cut iron.
Okay?
So, let us focus on cut iron.
Cut iron is inside
what is our central atom?
Central atom is silver.
And,
what is the ligand?
Ammonia.
Isn't it?
NH3 is.
So,
how much is ammonia?
It is 2.
So, what will happen?
It will be
diamine.
Okay?
So, the name of ligand is
because ammonia,
which is NH3,
is what we write as a ligand,
amine.
Right?
So, this is amine.
Diamine.
Now, what will happen?
What is our central atom?
What is here?
Silver.
After that,
the oxidation of silver
is written as
what is here?
Plus 1.
Okay?
So, what we wrote?
The name of cut iron is already written.
Now, it is anion.
So, let us focus on anion.
What is the central atom of anion?
Silver.
Right?
And, what is this?
CN whole 2.
Okay?
So, this is our ligand.
So, first we will write
CN.
CN minus.
I told you that anionic ligand
is negatively charged.
The name of anion always ends with O.
So, we will write this as
cyanido.
Okay?
O is placed in the last one.
It is placed.
Now, how many CN2 are there?
So, this will be di-syanido.
Okay?
I wrote di-syanido.
After that, what will we write?
Central atom.
So, this is called
silver.
But, here is a catch.
Now, look.
This whole anion.
Whenever we write anion,
the name of anion is written.
So, the name of anion is
the end of anion.
It ends with 8.
We all write 8.
This is the rule we just read.
It is a little difficult now.
But, once we practice it,
things will be easy.
So, here, this silver is
not written as silver.
Now, we cannot write silver 8.
So, the symbol of silver is A.G.
A.G.
Okay?
Now, in this bracket,
we have to write an oxidation number.
So, this is the must.
So, how many oxidation numbers are there?
1 again.
So, this 1.
So, it will be called
this is called
IUPSC.
Di-Syanido-Argent-1.
So, let us see the third example.
C-O-N-H-3-H-O-L-5-C-O-3-CL.
Okay?
Now, see what is the answer here?
First, you have to understand.
See, the things in the square bracket
are the coordination identity.
Now, whatever is outside is counter-ion.
So, C-L is counter-ion here.
C-L is the minus-ion of C-L.
What will happen?
This is our anion.
Negatively charged anion.
So, what is the part that is saved?
What is this?
This is our positively charged anion.
Okay?
First, we will always see the name of the cation.
Now, this cation is also in the cobalt
which is our central atom.
Okay?
And which is the ligand?
1 ligand is NH-3.
That is, the amine which we will name as amine.
The second is C-O-3, that is carbonate.
Okay?
So, this is our two ligands.
Come on.
So, let us start with the naming.
First of all, we will name the cation in the name of the cation.
So, what is the name of the ligand?
1 is amine.
How many amines are there?
NH-3 is the whole 5.
So, that is, the name of the plant will be named as pentamine.
The second ligand is called CO3.
CO3 is the number of charges.
Carbonate is the minus-charge in the time of carbonate.
That is, this is anionic ligand.
Negatively charged ligand.
Negatively charged ligand is the name of the name of the plant.
It is always the end of the day.
So, this will be called carbonate.
Okay?
Now, we will write carbonate before we write this.
Or, we will write amine first.
Amine is written as alpha-bethical order.
So, here we will write carbonate.
See, we do not put space anywhere.
Because it is also a rule that we have to put space in between.
Okay?
So, carbonate is also written.
So, this is the name of the ligand.
What is this?
So, this is the number of charges of carbonate.
It is called minus-2.
And overall, how much charge should be charged?
If the ionized is called as CL-2 and it is plus.
So, this is the number of charges.
It is the number of charges.
It is plus-1.
Okay?
So, here we can see that x value will be taken out of 3.
So, this means that cobalt cox addition state will be taken out of 3.
We will not write the Roman numeral.
So, in this way, we have done the naming of the entire cut iron.
And what is in the ion?
CL.
So, we will write it as chloride.
And we are done with the naming.
So, children, now I hope this part is clear that if a formula is given, how will we write its name?
Now, let us learn vice versa.
If we have given a name, how will we write its formula?
I mean, I know this is not rocket science, but still a step by step process on this.
Because if you do not follow the steps, you are confused.
So, how will we write the name?
So, look, if a formula is given and you have to write the name.
So, in this case, you have to follow 3 simple steps.
The first step is to identify the central atom.
First, you have to identify the structure of the formula or the formula of the structure of the formula.
Which one you are doing?
Second.
Identify the ligands in alphabetical order.
Which are ligands?
Which are directly attached directly to the central atom?
Which are directly bonded to the square brackets?
Which are ligands?
Identify the ligands.
So, do the alphabetical order.
So that you know that you have to write them in order.
Third, identify counter ions.
Which is counter ions?
Identify them.
If you have identified 3 things, then their name is super-duper easy.
Let us try something.
Let us see the example.
Potassium tetra hydroxozincate2.
First, we will identify what is the thing in it.
Okay.
Now, there is two in the form of zincate.
Which means that this zincate is basically our central atom.
Because the central atom is not the oxidation number in its form.
But at the same time, there is an A here.
Which means that this central atom is the part of anion.
Okay.
This is also understood.
So, we have found out that this part of the part is potassium.
This is counter ion.
Because this is central atom.
So, this is C i, counter ion.
Okay.
And this tetra hydroxozincate2 will be ligand.
So, this means ligand and this central atom will be in our square bracket.
And potassium will be outside.
Okay.
So, now, let us write this.
So, this means that potassium is removed outside.
Now, inside the square bracket.
What we will write?
We will write the first central atom that is zinc here.
And what is this?
Here is ligand.
Tetra hydroxo.
HydroxoboletohOH.
And how much OH is tetra?
That means 4.
So, Z and OH are 4.
Okay.
Now, see what is really going on?
Oxidation number again.
So, zincate's oxidation number is 2.
Okay.
So, what we will write is that if it is plus 2 charge.
And how much is in OH?
We know that it is minus 1.
But here, 4 is 4.
So, how much will it be?
Minus 4.
So, what we will write?
Net net.
In this square bracket, the inner ion.
This net net will be the charge of the inner ion.
Minus 2.
So, how much is the charge of potassium?
We know that it is plus 1.
So, this minus 2 will be here eventually.
This plus 1 will be here.
So, here it will be K2.
So, this will be the formula of K2 Z and OH whole 4.
So, the word theory has given us a lot of information.
Right?
It has been quite an idea.
We have a lot of coordination compounds.
There are a lot of them.
But in this theory, some of the items were still missing.
As said, what happens is that there are some elements that make coordination compounds.
Why not all of them?
What happens is that there are coordination compounds that are bond in it.
There are directional properties.
And because of that directional property,
they are their specific orientation and geometry.
Why is it so?
The coordination compounds are also specific,
optical and magnetic properties.
Right?
So, this is the question that the word theory was not given.
In other theories, it was not given.
After that, after that,
one more theory is given to explain all these things in more detail.
Like, balance bond theory,
crystal field theory,
I league and field theory,
and many more.
But in this case, we will not focus on all these theories.
We will focus only on two theories.
Balance bond theory and crystal field theory.
So, we will start with balance bond theory.
Now, we have to study the coordination compounds for the balance bond theory.
That is our agenda.
But before that,
let me check all these covalent compounds
that I read in the balance bond theory.
I read that, how much do you remember?
How much do you remember?
Someone will remember.
So, we will do a quick recap.
Because, without that recap,
we can understand the difficulty.
So, what was the case in the covalent compounds?
What was the balance bond theory?
Our story was that,
whenever we have to do bond formation,
then,
what does anyone do?
They send their balance or vitals to make bond.
That is, the balance of the electrons
and the electrons send them to make bond.
So, it is like,
like, in our country,
someone attacks.
So, who goes to the youth learn?
I and you are sitting at home in the starting,
who goes to the youth learn?
The boundary, the shoulders, the hands, the hands.
So, in a similar way,
who goes to make bond?
Balance or vitals.
Okay?
In fact, if I only say balance or vitals,
then it will be wrong.
Who goes to hybridized or vitals?
We read hybridization.
Basically, there is something that is related to the outside and the vital.
Right?
All the energy levels are different.
And we don't go there.
So, you should think about it.
If you are sitting on the border,
then, you can go to the fight.
No. Right?
The training for fighting with the shoulders
will go there.
Because, whatever the sun will be,
they are equally trained.
Their energy level is equal.
So, they are all the sides of the youth.
They are the sides of the learning.
You are understanding?
So, what is the story here?
That, whatever the balance or vitals are,
now, there is a 2P,
there is a 2P,
there is a different energy level.
We don't go there.
What do we do?
We say that,
all these energy levels,
we meet all these seven,
and distribute the energy
like good children equally.
And that's how we get hybridized or vitals of equivalent energy.
And, the hybridized or vitals of equivalent energy,
they are going to bond with other people.
This was our covalent compound case,
VBT, which means, the balance was bond theory.
Let's look at the example.
Let's talk about covalent compound.
Let's talk about methane.
If you look at the structure of methane,
which bond is formed between carbon and hydrogen?
Carbon is formed between carbon.
It has a hydrogen,
two hydrogen,
three hydrogen, four hydrogen,
so basically, it is formed in the middle of carbon and hydrogen.
Now, what I have said is,
that the hybridized or vitals of carbon
will participate in bond formation.
How?
Carbon electronic configuration,
1 is 2 2 is 2 2P2.
So, in the way,
these two-way 2P or vitals
should be known as bond.
But,
I have told you that,
two-way 2P is different energies.
So, they have said that,
they work together,
S and P,
three or vitals.
That is P, X, P, Y, PZ.
They have said that,
they are all together.
Okay?
You have so much energy,
give me so much energy,
they are all connected in the form of an equal power.
Okay?
So, there is something like this.
Here,
1S and 3P or vitals
combine together.
And,
these are formed
by hybridized SP-3 orbitals
of equivalent energy.
Now, these hybridized orbitals
are made more stable bond.
That is why,
hybridization is formed.
Right?
So, when the bond formation of methane
is formed,
then,
carbon has four SP-3 hybrid orbitals.
And,
these SP-3 hybrid orbitals
are made with this orbital
hydrogen,
and that is how methane is formed.
This is a covalent compound.
Now, let's see
what happens in the case of coordination compounds.
So, look, in coordination compounds,
the main funder is
the central metal atom
is accepted by electron.
Who accepts it?
Ligant.
Okay?
So, here, what happens here?
The central atom is
the hybrid orbital.
Right?
That means,
the outer orbital,
the valence orbital,
will be
hybridized.
As I was telling you right now,
then, after hybridization,
the hybrid orbitals
will be formed
with which,
they will overlap
and make the bond
with the ligand orbitals.
Absolutely correct?
Okay?
And, here,
there is a bond formation.
Okay?
The concept is also
that,
just that,
here,
there is a central metal atom
and a ligand
with the ligand orbitals,
with the central atom orbital.
And, here,
the central atom
is accepted by the ligand
electron.
It is
accepted.
What is the difference?
Let's see that.
And, we will understand that,
with the example.
Okay?
Let us suppose,
we take an example of
coordination compound.
Like,
CO NH3 whole 6,
CL3.
Okay?
So, here,
what is the central atom?
Cobalt,
that means,
CO.
Okay?
Here,
what is the ligand?
NH3 means the ammonia.
Okay?
Now,
we see,
from this formula,
you can see,
that,
in the cobalt,
there is a link between the two.
And,
this is the 6 coordination bond,
which is made by the 6 NH3.
Okay?
Which means,
this NH3,
which is the ligand,
what is the ligand here?
What is the thing here?
Electron,
is the thing here.
Cobalt,
what is the thing here?
Electron,
is accepted.
Basically,
it will be sharing,
but cobalt will not give any electrons.
Okay?
So,
if you think about it,
cobalt,
is to take 2 electrons from each NH3.
That is the whole purpose of cobalt.
Because cobalt is the central atom.
cobalt is not the one that is given to the body.
So,
cobalt will take 2 electrons from each NH3.
Okay?
So,
this means,
that if we make the cobalt configuration,
then,
we have to have 6 cobalt boxes.
We should have 6 cobalt boxes.
Let us see,
cobalt's electronic configuration is written.
So, let us talk about this particular,
complex and more detail.
Co NH3 whole 6 CL3.
So,
here, now,
we are focusing on the catan,
which is CO NH3 whole 6 3+.
Okay?
So, here,
cobalt's electronic configuration is the first thing we need to write.
So,
if we look at cobalt's electronic configuration,
then,
this outer configuration will be 3D7 4S2.
Okay?
If we make it in the dub,
then,
let us see,
what it will look like.
The D is 7,
that is,
in 5,
1 and the 2,
2 paired up.
3D7 is 7 and 4S2 is 4S2,
2 paired up electrons.
Okay?
Something like that.
The configuration of cobalt is absolutely fine.
Now,
let us see,
this particular complex,
cobalt's
oxidation number is so much.
Okay?
How we will take it out?
The number of cobalt's oxidation is X.
Okay?
NH3 is as large as it is,
0.
Okay?
And here,
NH3 is 6,
so 0 into 6 is 0.
So, X plus 0 is equal to
how much?
It has a net charge as much as plus 3.
So,
that means,
X value plus 3 is the
cobalt's plus 3 oxidation state.
Now, the cobalt's
electronic configuration is
written.
Now, see the
configuration of CO3 plus.
3 plus.
That means,
3 electrons have been cut out.
Where will they be cut?
2 electrons of 4S are cut out.
The 3D7 is
now,
3D6 will be considered.
Okay?
Something like that will be made.
Now,
if we look carefully,
what to do with cobalt?
To make a 6NH3 with co-ordinate bond.
That means,
we have to take two electrons
from each NH3.
Correct?
We have to take 12 electrons.
How many of these cobalt's
should we have?
At least 6 boxes.
Right?
But,
how many boxes are there?
4 boxes.
So, what will cobalt do?
We will adjust a little.
Right?
When we go to our house,
we do what?
We adjust a little.
Because,
there is no room in our house.
Anyways,
right?
So, now,
how to adjust cobalt?
Now,
there was only one
of four electrons in the house.
So, these people
just have to get a pair of dubs.
Okay?
Now, how many dubs are there?
Look.
Now, we have 6 dubs.
Right?
6 dubs.
Okay?
But,
these 6 dubs are
the first 2 dubs are
D orbital.
The next one is dubs.
Right?
Now, what is the energy level of these people?
It is different.
3d, 4s, 4p.
What is the energy level of these people?
It is different.
Okay?
We do not walk like this.
So, what we will do?
We will do hybridization.
So, this means,
2d2s1 and 3d3.
These people will
hybridize them in the future.
And, this will be
D2sp3 hybrid orbitals
of equivalent energy.
Okay?
We have done it.
I understand.
Okay.
Now, what will happen when the bond formation will be?
Look, these hybrid orbitals
will be in the electron pair.
Where will it come?
In H3, it will be in H3.
It will be in the work of the electron pair.
So, in H3, it will be in the electron pair.
And, that is how
electron pairs will come.
So, what we have seen here?
In this particular
complex case,
cobalt coordination number
was 6.
Because, this was
making a bond with 6 ligand.
In this case,
what is the hybridization of this?
D2sp3.
And, in this case,
for coordination number
6, which is the hybridization
D2sp3,
what is its geometry?
What is it?
What is its special arrangement?
That is octahedral.
So, look,
this balance bond theory
comes, right?
With a particular
coordination compound,
we have
made a specific
geometry link.
Right?
Now, we will take
another example.
So, here we will see
how,
just like
coordination number
changes,
like hybridization changes,
and
like this,
the special arrangement
also changes.
Right?
So, now, we will take
our next example,
which is COCl42-
So, here my central atom
is cobalt,
which is CO,
and which is the ligands
from which it is chlorine.
And, how much
CO is attached to it?
4.
So, here,
how much CO is
cobalt?
4.
Simple, right?
Now, let us
consider its bond formation
and hybridization.
CO is
outer electronic configuration
3D7 4S2.
Here, in this particular
complex,
what is the oxidation state of CO is?
CO is
how much CO is
minus 1.
Here, 4 CO is
the total,
minus 4.
CO is
the quantity of CO,
so, X plus minus 4 is equal to,
overall,
how much CO is
minus 2 in this complex?
So, X value
plus 2, that is,
cobalt is here
plus 2 in this state.
So, cobalt
2 plus CO2 plus
what will be
the electronic configuration?
4 is 2
of the 2 electrons,
let them
get out.
So,
now, how do I
consider 3D7?
So, that means,
the d-value
orbital
which is the double,
it has one electron
and the first two
have two electrons.
Okay?
It is clear here.
Now, what will happen?
Now,
let's see how many
of these
are going to be eaten.
Let's think.
We have to make a bond
with these 4 clonies.
That means,
we have to make 4
of these 4 clonies.
Because each of these
has two electrons.
What is the
4 clonies
and the
4 clonies?
It is the
1 clonies and the
3 clonies and the
This is
available.
So, this is not
more adjustment.
This is the
orbital orbital
and the
3 clonies
are the
orbitals of
equivalent energy.
And this is the
hybrid orbital
which is the bond
in the
formation.
Okay?
I understood.
So, this means,
here, the coordination
was 4.
The hybridization
was the
S-P-3.
And when the
hybridization
is the S-P-3,
then,
how is the
spatial arrangement?
It is
the tetrahedral
absolutely correct.
That is,
our cobalt is
sitting in the middle
and a tripod stand.
Like this,
there is a clonies
and a clonies
and a clonies.
So, this
way, the
COCL-42-
So, let's
take a
more next example.
Okay?
It is
a little interesting.
So, the next
compound is
Ni-CN-42-
So, here,
central atom is
nickel Ni.
And here,
ligand is
CN. So,
CN-4 is
making this
4-coordinate bond,
meaning,
here, coordination
is 4.
Okay?
Now, you think
that if
coordination is 4,
then, this
tetrahedral will
be S-P-3-hybridization.
But, not really,
wait.
What happens here?
Okay?
So, let's start
from where,
from nickel,
the electronic configuration?
3D-8-4-2
outer configuration.
Okay?
Now, the next step is,
what is the
oxidation state in this particular
compound?
Now,
CN-4 is
the minus 1 here.
there is
a total minus 4.
So,
nickels is
x. So, x plus
minus 4 is equal to
here,
overall charge
minus 2. So,
the x-value
plus 2, which means,
nickel is
plus 2 oxidation
state.
Okay?
Now,
what will be the
2-coordinate
configuration of Ni2
plus 2?
Let's run the
2-coordinate
configuration.
So, now,
what is the
configuration of this
In between 3D-8,
D photonic
is equal to
So,
to make a bond with the TN because I have 4 CNs, so you will give 2 electrons each.
Now, let's see what happens here.
There is a drop in the chart.
But what happens is that the D in the heart is that the 1st electron is 1 kg.
So I will shift both the two.
I will pair both the two together.
Well, it is like this that 1st is 1 kg.
The gas is not there, they will accommodate the rest in the room.
But what we think is that the 1st electron is so big that it has 1 kg.
Both of them are shifting.
So, somewhat like that.
So, what happens here?
What happens is that the D is 1 drop.
Now, I have 4 drops.
So, I have taken 1 D, 1 S, 2 P.
So, I have taken 2 P.
So, the third drop is not used.
Now, the energy level is different.
So, D, S and P2.
These are all hybridized.
D, S, P2 hybrid orbitals of equivalent energy.
So, here, there is still coordination number 4.
But, here, what is hybridization?
D, S, P2.
Because hybridization is D, S, P2.
So, here, the special arrangement is that is square planar.
So, if you look at the structure of NICN whole 4, 2 minus,
then this is a square planar.
That means, in NICN, it is like a square that is lying in a plane.
Where, NICN is in NICN and is on the 4 corners of the square.
So, in any way, we can see other coordination compounds examples.
Where, coordination number 5 is hybridization of S, P3D.
And, there, the special orientation of the orientation is
Tri-Gonal by Pyramidal.
Like, FECO whole 5.
Here, you can see, the central atom is iron.
This is 5 CO jude.
That is, coordination number 5.
FEF6, 3 minus.
So, here, in the central atom,
the total 6 ligands are jude, which means coordination number 6.
Here, if you look at the hybridization,
you can see that hybridization comes out to be S, P3D2.
And, here, the special orientation will be octahedron.
So, if we take an example of FECO whole 6, 4 minus.
So, here, we will see coordination number 6C.
Because, with iron, the total 6 CN jude is there.
But, here, the hybridization is D2SP3.
And, here, the special arrangement is, that is, again, octahedron.
So, now, we will discuss about magnetic behavior.
Okay.
We are discussing the valence bond theory,
so, we will see that, when we make this structure,
we see that, after hybridization,
the central atom's orbitals are unpaired electrons.
If, unpaired electron is present,
that means, it is paramagnetic.
If, unpaired electron is not present,
that means, it is a diamagnetic.
Okay.
Let us take an example.
Let us take an example of CONH3 whole 6, 3 plus.
Okay.
We have just done the whole calculation.
So, what we have seen is, this hybridization is D2SP3.
Okay.
So, if we look at this, in some way,
this is 6D2SP3 hybrid orbitals of equivalent energies,
which are brought by electrons from NH3.
That is, from ligands to electron pairs, which are brought by them.
Okay.
Now, see, from all the dots,
see from the DNA, in some way,
that you are not seeing unpaired electrons.
This means, unpaired electron is not present,
which means, this is diamagnetic in nature.
Simple.
Okay.
Now, one more thing we can tell you.
This complex, you know, this is the way it is complex.
This inner orbital complex.
If you say inner orbital complex,
this complex is used to make this complex.
The d orbital is being used,
this inner d orbital is being used.
If you look here, if we look at the cobalt orbitals,
which orbital is hybridized?
D2SP3.
This D2 is D2D3D2.
Right.
The two D2 orbitals are D3D2 orbitals.
That is, the outermost shell,
that is actually 4.
Look at the 4S4P,
but the D is 3D.
That means, the inner D orbitals are being used here
for bond formation.
That is why, we call this way inner orbital complex.
Okay.
That means, for bond formation,
these inner d orbitals are used here,
they are inner orbital complex.
So, let us go ahead and look at the exercise.
Let us suppose, we have a complex COCl42-
and we have to predict the shape and its magnetic behavior.
So, where do we start from?
From the central atom.
Okay.
Here, what is the central atom?
CO, that is, cobalt.
Okay.
What is the electronic configuration of cobalt?
We will focus on the outer electronic configuration.
So, its outer electronic configuration is 3D7, 4S2.
So, if I make it in such blocks,
this is how it will look.
D1, 2, 3, 4, d1.
And S1 is one.
So, 3D7 means 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7,
3D7 and 4S2.
So, this 3D is 4S.
So, as it is, this is the electronic configuration.
But, let us see that cobalt is in this particular complex.
What is the state?
That means, what is the oxidation number of cobalt here?
So, let us suppose,
cobalt oxidation number X is CL of minus 1.
And here, how much CL is 4CL?
So, that means, how much will be total?
Minus 4.
This is equal to net net in minus 2 charge.
So, X value will be plus 2.
So, that means, cobalt is here in 2 plus state.
Okay.
So, cobalt is 2 plus, what is the electronic configuration?
Let us see.
So, cobalt is 2 plus, the electronic configuration will be like this.
Let us take out 2 electrons.
So, 2 electrons are straight away from 4S.
So, now, how will this configuration be?
This will be 3D7.
Okay.
Because, if we take out 2 electrons from 4S,
cobalt will be in 2 plus state.
So, this is the configuration now.
Okay.
So, now, let us see that cobalt should be equal to 1.
How much is the quantity of cobalt?
How much is the quantity of cobalt combined with cobalt?
With chlorine.
How much is CL?
4CL.
So, cobalt should be equal to 4.
Now, if we look here, only 1 is the quantity of cobalt.
This 4S is the quantity of cobalt.
But, after 4S, 4P cobalt will be equal to 2.
Because, both are valentials.
Both are the outer shells corresponding to n is equal to 4.
So, both are outer shells.
So, this means, this 4 is the quantity of cobalt.
What will happen?
This is the hybridized cobalt.
We will make SP3 hybrid orbitals.
And, this is the SP3 hybrid orbital.
We will participate in this bond formation with this CL.
Okay.
So, I understood all these things.
I wanted to tell you, I wanted to tell you,
this is the magnetic behavior and shape.
So, if SP3 hybridization is done,
and how much is its coordination number?
4 is because cobalt is equal to 1 chlorine.
So, you see, what does it say here?
4 if its coordination number is,
and type of hybridization is SP3.
So, how will it shape?
Its tetrahedral shape.
Cocl 4 2 minus its shape, tetrahedral.
So, by shape, we have told you.
Now, the magnetic behavior of the magnetic behavior,
how we will tell you,
is there an unpaired electron here?
Sir, sir, sir, sir, is there an unpaired electron here?
In the boom, right?
If there is an unpaired electron,
then how will this magnetic nature be?
This will be the paramagnetic.
So, how we will tell you this,
shape and magnetic behavior.
So, let us see the other example.
The other example is CRH2O whole 6 3 plus.
So, here our central atom is called chromium.
Okay?
So, the same process will follow.
So, first of all,
tell me about the chromium.
Atomic number is 24.
So, if we write its electronic configuration.
So, what will we get?
Its outer configuration.
If we focus on it,
its outer configuration will be 3D5 4S1.
Okay, you can see the electronic configuration
written here.
The outer configuration will be here.
Okay, 3D5 is the reason.
Because half field is more stable.
So, it takes 4S1 and 3D5.
Okay, so, this is the configuration.
Now, we have to see that chromium is in this complex state.
Here, you see,
the number of chromium oxidation is x.
The water is 0.
It is the net net plus 3.
So, that is the value of x.
It is the value of 3.
That is, chromium is here in plus 3 state.
So, CR3 plus.
How will this configuration be?
Let us make boxes here.
Okay.
So, first situation was like this.
3D5 and 4S1.
And 4P is also here, but it is empty.
Okay, this situation was.
Now, what will happen in CR3 plus?
4S will be 1.
It will be 2.
So, this will be 3D3.
So, what will happen in the situation of W here?
1, 2, 3.
And the rest will be empty.
Okay.
So, this is 3D, this is 4S, this is 4P.
Okay, so, you see, here,
how much W is empty here?
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6.
This is 6 boxes empty.
Okay.
And look, here,
the compound in which chromium is in,
is made from 2O.
That is, 6D is empty.
So, what will this do?
This is 2D1S and this is 3P.
We will make all these hybridized.
D2SP3 hybrid orbitals.
Okay.
And this is D2SP3 orbitals,
which are made with H2,
in bond formation.
Okay.
So, tell us on this basis, what will happen in shape?
Okay, coordination number is 6,
because this is connected with H2O.
So, that means, my coordination number is 6.
What is my hybridization?
D2SP3, that is the hybridization
and its corresponding shape,
what will happen?
Its corresponding shape will be octahedral.
Okay.
This is the complex of the way.
I had told you.
Here, look,
D orbitals are participating here.
Because the outermost shell is equal to 4.
But D orbitals are participating
in the corresponding value of 3.
So, this is an inner orbital complex.
Okay.
If we talk about this,
what is the unpaired electron in this?
It is clearly visible.
I am here, unpaired electron.
So, just write down the number of these.
This is para-magnetic.
Okay.
And you are done.
Now, the number of verna theory
has overcome many limitations.
Valence bond theory had overcome.
But, in Valence bond theory,
there were still some limitations left.
The first limitation was that
there were many assumptions in this theory.
The second was that,
the magnetic data was given
that there was no quantitative interpretation.
It didn't give it.
As I told you,
unpaired electron is not like that,
it is not like that.
But, there was no quantitative interpretation
for the same.
Coordination compounds
exhibit this color.
But, in Valence bond theory,
nothing was told about this.
Coordination compounds
have no kinetics and kinetics
about the thermodynamics and the kinetics.
The coordination compounds
have coordination number four.
There is a tetrahedral
spatial arrangement
and a square plane arrangement.
But, these two different situations
are not known
as the two different situations.
This theory was not understood.
This is not the first time that
This theory was not understood
by any difference between
What was the next theory?
The next theory
is that, we will discuss
the next theory of Philalge's
crystal field theory.
So, let's understand the crystal field theory.
Before that, we have to understand
the basic concept of the energy of orbitals.
This is what we know
that all the energies of the orbitals
are different.
Like, the p orbitals,
the d orbitals,
are different in all the energies of the orbitals.
Now, if you talk about the d orbitals,
then 5 d orbitals are different.
And, they are the same in all the energies.
Like, d x y d y z d x z d x z square
minus y square d z square.
In fact, if you look at all these d orbitals
of the d x y d y z d z z,
the lobes of the d y z
are the coordinates of the coordinates
of the d x z z.
And, in the same way,
d x z square minus y square
and d z z square in the case of the d x z square,
they are the coordinates of the coordinates of the coordinates.
So, this structure is to be taken care of in the brain.
So, the crystal field theory will be understood better.
So, now, all these d orbitals
have the same energies.
They are called d generate orbitals
and this concept is called d generate.
So, now, all these energies
are the same till date.
Till date,
they have a symmetric field.
So, that means,
you understand.
I am standing like this.
Now, I am standing from here.
And, I am standing from the same side.
So, what will happen?
I will stand like this.
I will remain like this.
There will be no change in my position.
But, I believe that
no one is standing from the same side.
So, what will happen?
My position will be shifted.
So, here,
there is a difference.
If the field is symmetrical,
then, all these d generates
are the energies of the d.
But, if a symmetrical field comes from there,
then what happens is that
their d generates are completely finished.
Okay.
Now, the ligand field theory
is that,
when ligand's entry
is attached to the central atom,
then what happens is that,
the field that is
around the central atom
is called as asymmetric.
What happens because of that?
The d generates of the d,
that is,
the d that is
5 d orbitals
are different from their energies.
And, the d orbitals
split.
What happens is that,
split of d.
Now, how is the pattern of the splitting?
It depends on the nature of the crystal field.
Okay.
So, more or less,
an overview is understood.
So, let's see what happens in the
crystal field theory.
Now, the crystal field
is the octahedral crystal field.
This tetrahedral crystal field
and, in this crystal field,
it depends on the nature of the d orbital splitting.
Okay.
So, first of all,
we will talk about the octahedral crystal field.
Okay.
What does the octahedral entities say in the case of the case?
What does the CFT say?
So, CFT is going to be a very fun
to see a story.
Okay.
So, what happens in this?
The problem is that,
the ligand field theory is the ligand.
So, the ligand,
that is,
attacks our central atom.
In this theory.
Okay.
Now, you can see two things.
As you know,
I am standing here.
Okay.
Now, my enemy,
who sees me,
is very angry.
Now, if he is
standing here,
then what will happen?
My and my enemy's repulsion
will be much more angry.
Right?
But, if I stand here,
and my enemy is
like this,
from here.
So, in that case,
the repulsion of the tetrahedral
is less,
logical, makes sense.
Now, there is something like this.
Look.
When the ligand
is approaching the central atom,
then,
the electron in the ligand
also has the electron
between the electron and the electron.
Okay.
Now, this repulsion
is the same.
If,
the ligand attacks
in the axis,
your orbital
also in the same axis.
Right?
That means,
it is getting a head-on.
It is getting a head-on.
So, in that case,
the repulsion is more
and it gets more
energy level.
Okay.
Now, what happens?
In the case of the octahedral.
The ligand
attacks the central atom.
Along the axis.
Okay.
So, the d-
of the orbitals,
which are along the axis,
which is the same.
Which of the d-
of the orbitals,
which are along the axis,
which is the same.
Think quickly.
d-
of the square minus y square
and d-z square.
So, what happens
for these orbitals?
The repulsion is very
much in this case.
The energy level
of the emicron is very
much.
Right?
So, the first situation
was that,
the 5 orbitals of the d-
of the orbital were all the same.
Now, what happens?
The 2 d-
of the orbital
of the emicron is
more than the energy level.
The other 3 were
the other 3 levels were less than the energy level.
Because the overall energy
would not be that much.
If the 3 is bigger,
then the rest
if the 2 is bigger,
then the rest 3
are not the same.
Right?
So, what happened at the end of the day?
The first 5 was
now,
the 2 and 5 split.
This is called
splitting of the orbitals.
Okay?
Okay.
So, now I have
met the overall splitting
and I have met 2 sets.
One set above
is called
the higher energy set,
which is called
EEG set.
The lower energy set
is called
T2G set.
Okay?
It is clear.
So, the child
here, we have seen
that the splitting
of the orbitals
due to the presence of a ligand,
in a particular geometry,
this is called
crystal field splitting.
So, this is
the main crystal field
theory concept.
Okay?
Now, the splitting
and the
two levels
have split.
The difference between the
energy that is
denoted by
delta O,
where the subscript O
stands for
octahedron.
So, this delta O
tells us
magnitude of
crystal field splitting.
Very carefully,
what happens?
This is totally
EEG and T2G's
difference between the
difference of the
T2G's difference.
Now, the energy
of the EG is
so much bigger.
That is,
the first one,
how much EG is
bigger?
How much
it will be so much
other three levels?
Right?
So, this EG is
so much bigger.
That is 3 by 5 of delta O.
That is, the
whole delta O
is the difference.
That is, how much
the EG is
so much bigger.
3 by 5 of delta O
and how much
the T2G is
so much bigger.
That is, 2 by 5 of delta O.
Okay?
Now, you will think
that the EG is
the same level.
In that,
there are two
energy orbitals.
Two orbitals.
So, how much
the bigger three by 5 of the EG is?
Why not 2 by 5 of the EG?
Because, look, the two
orbitals of the EG are
bigger than the
Because of the other three
of the EG,
that is, 3 by 5 of delta O.
So, in the same way,
the other three of the EG
are bigger than the other three.
Because the other
two of the EG is
bigger than the other two
by 5 of the EG.
So, in this way,
you can remember
Okay?
So, what we have
said is that by D
or a orbital,
the degenerate
of the EG is
split, the Q is split,
in the presence of a ligand,
it is said
that the crystal field is
splitting.
How much splitting is
the same?
The energy difference
between the two levels,
that is,
delta O. Okay?
The top level is
the height of the EG
is 3 by 5 of the EG.
The lower level is
the T2G,
the height of the EG
is 2 by 5 of delta O.
The crystal field is
the same with the
It is the
strong and weak
ligand concept.
As you have seen,
there are some
ligands that
are very
very tight splitting.
In the presence of
the bone ligands,
the splitting is
very high.
That is, the
delta value is
very high.
The other way
is, the ligands
are very weak.
They are very
very low.
They are
less than the
delta value.
So, the
strong ligands
that are
ligands that are
They are
Now, experimentally,
a series
will determine that
the extent of the
constant ligand is
very tight.
Okay?
So, the series is
something that is
visible and we say
spectrochemical series.
Okay?
So, if you look at this
series, the
ligand strength
of the name of the
name of the
Cn-, as
i-br-
Cn-
this is all
weak ligands.
In the other
way, if we look at
Cn-co, this is
all strong ligands.
So, now we have
seen that, the
D orbital is now
split in two levels.
Okay?
The lower energy
level, that is
T2g, the higher
energy level,
that is EG.
Okay?
Now, we have
seen that the
electron of the D orbital
is assigned in
this order.
Where is
the electron
of the D orbital?
The first
electron of the D orbital
is the first electron
where it will be.
Obviously, the
lower energy level will be
at the lower energy.
That is, the
more stability and
sublux table.
So, the first electron
is a good
child.
T2g will be
in the T2g.
Okay?
Now, the second electron
is the
T2g.
But where
will T2g be in the T2g?
The same electron
will be
paired with the
next box.
Next box
because
the Hunds rule
is called
Hunds rule.
We read it
in the 11th class.
Hunds rule is
that the
electron filling
is the first
electron in the
entire D orbital.
After that,
the first
D orbital is
paired with the first D orbital.
So, here
it will be like this.
Now, the third electron
is here.
Where will it be?
It will be in the T2g
but the third D orbital
will be in the D orbital.
Now, the fourth
electron is
here.
Here, it comes
in the back.
Where will the
electron be?
There is
one option
that the first D orbital
is paired
with the first D orbital.
But if it is paired,
what will it be?
It will
have to be paired.
It will have to be paired
with the first D orbital.
Okay.
Now, if
it is not
going to be paired,
it will not be the
first D orbital.
It will not be the first D orbital.
So,
there is
another option
that
it will be paired
with the first D orbital.
Now, if
it is not going to be paired
with the first D orbital.
A T2g is
it is
D orbital that
Suppose it is a T2g
energy level. So what will we need to buy? Delta O crystal field energy right crystal
field splitting energy will have to buy that. So basically electron this electron where
will go? It depends on which value is less. Delta O value is less or the
power of the energy value is less. Okay, where the value of the energy will also go there.
So if you consider the value of the energy value of the power of the energy, then what will
we do in that case? This will go to the T2G level and it will go to the power of the
power of the delta O. So what will we do? This will go to the EG level of the
crystal field. Okay, so if this crystal field goes to the EG level, then how will we see
its configuration? T2G3 EG1 means T2G level is 3 electrons and EG is 1 electron.
If this is not going to be the code, when it will not go, when its power energy will
reduce from delta O. Right? So in such a case, if this is going to be the power of the
energy, then let's go to the power of the power. So in such a case, its configuration
will go to T2G4 EG0. So this is two situations, I understood. Now let's see the
two situations. The value of the delta O in which the situation is more. Right?
So the value of the delta O is more than the energy of the two, and the power of the
energy of the power is less. What was the configuration we got? We got T2G4 EG0. So
in such a situation, how will we create ligands? Strong field ligands. Strong ligands.
Why? In such cases, see the value of the delta O is more than, that is, splitting is
much more and which is more than, which is more than, which is stronger field ligands.
And in this way, strong field ligands make such complexes, low spin complexes. Why
low spin complexes? Because here, the pairing is starting. Right? Ten by unpaired electrons
here less. So here, we will make low spin complexes. In other case, in the
pairing energy value is more compared to delta O. This means delta O is less.
This means splitting is less. That is, how do ligands involve here? Weak field ligands
involve here. And in such a case, what is the value of the delta O? So electrons
think that this is the real number, so let us go to the corner. So this corner goes to
EG. So here, the electronic configuration is going to be, EG1, T2G3. Okay? So in such
cases, the complexes are made, they are high spin complexes. Because we get unpaired electrons
everywhere. So now we will see crystal field theory in case of tetrahedral entities.
Means, the crystal field of the molecule is tetrahedral. So in such a case, how
much will it be split? So here, situation will be a little twisted. What will be here?
The ligand, which we will attack in between the axis. Okay? Now because this is
attacking in between the axis, so the most repulsion, which experience will do? Those
D orbitals are low spin between the axis. Which one is the D orbitals? D x, y, D y,
D x, y, D y, D y, D y, D y and D y. So here, what is the D orbital splitting?
So the D orbital splitting was invert. First the bottom was above, first the top was
above, below. Okay? Second important thing here, we notice that, here the splitting
the energy separation of the octahedral is less.
The octahedral has the energy separation of delta O.
The energy separation of delta O is denoted by delta T, where T stands for tetrahedral.
This is the point that delta T is equal to 4 by 9 of delta O, which means delta T is less than delta O.
Another interesting thing is that we note here,
as we saw in the case of octahedral, the lower set was T2G, the upper set is EG.
What is now is the invert, so obviously the lower set is E, the upper set is T2.
Did you notice that both the places are G-guys.
Why is G-guys?
Because G actually stands for Gerard.
G is a German word, which means even, that is, the same symmetry about the inversion center.
So, that symmetry is not in tetrahedral entities, because of which we have not used G-subscript.
Now, we are going to talk about the color in coordination compounds.
Coordination compounds exhibit color, but there is no balance point theory about this.
It was not known, but crystal field theory was not known.
What was it known? Let us see.
So, this coordination compounds exhibit color, it has reason, electron transition from D or bital to D or bital.
That means, DD electron transition is the cause of this.
Now, you will ask, what is DD electron transition?
Now, look, when ligands present are not present, according to crystal field theory,
if ligand present is not present, then D or bital's splitting will not be present.
And in such a situation, which is compound, it will be colorless.
But, as ligand comes in the picture, it becomes split in D or bital.
That means, D or bital's split in two sets, it becomes a less energy-like energy.
What happens to it?
It happens to know that there is an electron in the ground state, which is less energy-like in D or bital.
If it gets energy from somewhere, then it reaches the excited state of the quid.
How it reaches? Because, the energy that is absorbed by it, absorbs an amdlent, absorbs it.
And, it absorbs it, and it gets absorbed in the excited state, quid, quid, quid.
But, an excited state is never stable.
So, what happens? In a little while, it does fall back in the ground state.
When it falls back, then it emits something, and emits that corresponding color, we see in those coordination compounds.
So, in those coordination compounds, where does that color come from?
It comes from the electron's quid, which comes from electron D or bital, and it comes from other D or bital.
In those times, all this color is silted.
And, this will be the transition of D or bital, when it becomes splitting, all D or bital is energy-like.
And, when it becomes splitting, it will be present.
So, this is what exactly the crystal field theory explains for the color of coordination compounds.
Now, let us take an example.
For example, let us take this coordination compound, TiH2O whole 6, 3 plus.
Here, what is central atom? Ti titanium.
So, Ti is the configuration of Ti, that is 3D2, 4S2.
Next, we have to see here, that in this particular compound, what is the oxidation state of Ti?
How did the oxidation state take? All of them went to see it.
Very good.
So, let us notice that Ti is the oxidation state of T plus 3.
So, what will be the configuration of Ti 3 plus?
Let us run both the electrons of 4S, and run one electron of 3D.
So, Ti 3 plus will be the outer configuration of 3D1.
That means, there is only one electron in 3D orbital.
Very good. Now, look at the crystal field theory's according, what is H2O here?
H2O is ligand.
So, what will be the presence of H2O?
The splitting of D or bital will be fine.
What will be the splitting of D or bital?
The bottom will be T2G, the top will be EG.
Now, this is 3D1, which means, there is only one electron in D.
So, where will this electron go? Obviously, it will go to T2G.
Because, T2G is lower energy orbital.
Now, what will be the conclusion with this electron?
If we get some extra energy from this electron, then this ground state will go to an excited state.
That is, what is the configuration of the ground state?
T2G1EG0.
And if we get the energy in the excited state, then what will be the configuration of the excited state?
T2G0EG1.
Okay.
As we have gone there, what happened?
It absorbed some lambda and reached there.
But, that table is not there.
It is in a little while.
It is fallbacked.
It was emitted by some lambda.
And that lambda, which emitted by it, was the corresponding color that was violet.
And that is why, this compound, this TIH2O whole 63 plus A, this is violet in color.
Okay.
Now, consider that I have said that if I drop water in this complex, this whole H2O is drop.
So, what will be the color?
So, this color will be less.
Because, the water is here, here, ligand.
And in the presence of ligand, the splitting of D orbital is there.
When the ligand is not there, then D orbital is there.
So, where will the color come from?
So, TIH2O whole 63 plus A, if we remove water, then this will make it colorless.
Now, here comes a small concept that the coordination compounds color, what color they show?
Basically, the wavelength absorbed, the complementary color, that color, this is the color.
Okay.
So, the wavelength absorbed.
Let us say that wavelength is for red.
For example, okay.
So, the red complementary color, red complementary color could be green.
So, this compound will show us green.
Okay.
Now, you ask me, what is complementary colors?
Complementary colors are like contrast colors.
Okay.
Both are different.
The contrast is the same.
Contrast means, I mean, if you mix these two colors, then you will get a cancel out of the effect of one of them.
If you mix both, then you will get white or black.
Okay.
For example, red or green, these two are complementary colors.
For example, violet and yellow, these are complementary colors.
For example, blue or orange, these are complementary colors.
Okay.
So, in this way, if you look at this diagram, then you can see the complementary colors are visible in opposite.
So, complementary colors are one of the strongest contrasts.
Okay.
So, what I understood is, why is color is in that too?
And what color is in that too?
I understood that too.
Right?
Now, children, there is no doubt that the crystal field theory explained a lot of things.
A lot of the balance bond theory that they have overcome with limitations.
But what is it?
There is a little bit of work in the world.
So, crystal field theory is also keeping its limitations.
As a first limitation was that the theory of crystal field theory, which was also based on assumptions and theories,
was based on its principle, that the anionic ligands, which is negatively charged ligands,
will behave like strong ligands.
But, when we saw experimentally determined spectrochemical series,
we saw that I-BR- this was all weak ligands.
Right?
So, this was a first limitation.
The second limitation was that the central atom and ligand's bondings,
which is not even a theory about the covalent character of that bond,
and it is not even a count.
So, the coordination of the bondings,
the coordination of the bondings, was very useful in the beginning.
As we have seen in our biological systems,
there are many important things, like chlorophyll, hemoglobin,
and vitamin B12, which are not so much of the coordination compounds.
In industrial purposes, these use of very good catalysts,
in medicinal industry, in photographic industry,
in all these, there are many applications.
Many more processes, coordination compounds,
have a very important role,
such as the hardness of water,
the estimation process,
the extraction process of metal.
So, in the cool,
the coordination compounds,
we have been thinking about these things for a long time.
So, with the help of the child,
you can come to this video's end,
and I hope that,
seeing this video,
and the coordination compounds,
the concepts of the bondings,
and if it is so,
please write in the comments,
that the concept is crystal clear.
I will soon meet a new video,
with a more powerful concept.
Till then, stay home, stay safe, take care, bye-bye.